so I'm delighted to be here and I'm
going to talk to you today about imaging
research mostly i'm going to focus on
imaging research that we're doing in our
laboratory here at yale and so part of
this is to you know educate you about
the work that we're doing educate you
about the field broadly but also frankly
it's to help recruit talented young
students like yourself to work in the
laboratory here so watch this with with
that in mind and feel free to interrupt
me at any point in time and i'll try to
save plenty of time for questions at the
end as well so we're interested in this
construct of social perception in the
lab if you have to define this you're
thinking about the initial stages of
processing that allow you to accurately
figure out or diagnose and other
person's intentions on the basis of
their actions so think about biological
motion in terms of where they're looking
the ways in which they're walking etc
how you use those cues to figure out
someone's intentions and also something
about their psychological dispositions
even things about their personality and
I'd like to show this as an example so
what is this you might have seen one of
your other speakers present some of
these this is easy not a trick question
a person walking thank you so you're
able to figure that out based on a
fairly impoverished stimulus and what
we've done is just place infrared lights
on the major joints of a person and
filmed them in the dark the camera that
was sensitive to infrared light and so
via these simple points of light given
the way they're moving you're able to
very very rapidly discern that this is a
person walking so I'm interested in how
the brain accomplishes that and
typically developing people it turns out
that it's been very interesting to think
about how the brain might fail at that
in people with autism and so in addition
to saying it's a person walking are they
guilty proud or embarrassed
it's a little harder but Speak Up guilty
proud thank you so hopefully most of you
see this person walking as proud they're
conveying pride in the way in which
they're walking right so again this is a
stimulus that's very impoverished in
terms of what hits your retina but
nonetheless your brain allows you via
your experiences and representations
that you've built up and the the actual
realization of those representations in
neurons in particular parts of your
brain to understand that this is a
person and they're proud right so we're
interested in how human beings
accomplish this in the argument behind
all this research is that human beings
have evolved something we call the
social brain right so the notion here is
that by virtue of their unique demands
for for social information processing we
as human beings have built these modules
for doing things like individuating
others perceiving agents and their
actions perceiving other people's
emotional states analyzing intentions
and motivations sharing attention and
intentions and then representing another
person's perceptions and beliefs what
I've done here even is purposely put
these in order in a way that I think
they actually build upon one another so
very very young infants are able to
individuate others perhaps from birth
perhaps very shortly after birth
perceiving agents and their actions
perceiving emotional states takes a
little bit longer but still something
done within the first year of life
analyzing intentions and motivations the
first year to year and a half of life
you begin to develop this and over the
course of the first three to four years
of life you're using what you've built
sort of in a bootstrap fashion from
these early types of information
processing to do things that the we as
adults do representing another person's
perceptions and their belief so even we
can figure out what other people are
looking at and we can make inferences
about what they're looking at make
inferences about what they're thinking
about by virtue of understanding their
perception and then we can begin to
understand how the why of what
people do so we not only just see what
they do but we start to understand that
there's a why underneath it and that why
is sometimes not based on reality as we
know it so they might think something
else is true and therefore act upon that
something else and so as human beings
when you start to understand that other
people are acting on the basis of what
they believe then that opens up a whole
other world well their type of reasoning
that you can do so we're interested in
how the social brain what are the parts
of the social brain that allow you to do
each one of these how do they work
together in order to do the more
complicated aspects of it and then
fundamentally how is that altered in a
disorder like autism which we view as
social information processing disorder
so to give you some names and locations
of regions I'll talk extensively about
the superior temporal sulcus today and
this is a region along your temporal
lobe you think just above your ear I'll
talk a lot about the right superior
temporal sulcus today in the posterior
part of it so imagine a region just
above your ear I'll talk about the
amygdala quite a bit this deep limbic
structure I've brought it to the surface
here to show you where roughly it's
located but to think about that as being
projected down into the brain it's a
deep limbic structure orbital frontal
cortex I'll talk about briefly in terms
of its role in representing reward value
especially social reward something
that's very relevant to our
understanding of autism and I'll talk
about a ventral region here on the
surface of the temporal lobe on the
bottom surface of the temporal lobe
that's selectively involved in
processing faces we'll talk about its
role in face perception deficits in
autism so as I've already revealed a bit
what I'm most interested in in the
context of autism is the qualitative
impairments in social interaction by now
you've already learned that autism is a
diagnosed and identified by this triad
of deficits as a syndrome I see the
qualitative impairments and social
interaction as the key to understanding
the entire disorder I see the other two
aspects of autism is emerging from these
fundamental deficits and social
information processing so that's why
we're interested in things like the
social brain
we think that by understanding normal
social brain development it'll give us a
fundamental insight into autism so the
two findings i want to show you that
will sort of occupy or justify
everything else i show you today one is
that individuals with autism fail to
spontaneously look at the eyes this is
something that anybody that's ever met a
child with autism could have told you
but we as scientists wanted to quantify
it and this was one of the first studies
that I was involved in as a scientist in
autism I had been using an eye tracker
to study infants in the way in which
infants look at faces so I wanted to
understand just across typical
development when is it that infants
start to really start scanning the eyes
and the core emotionally informative
features of the face and I wanted to
understand that so that we could
understand how infants represent
emotions and so I had the opportunity to
see some patients with autism and these
were adults with autism and I had been
studying three to seven week old infants
and I had seen that at about five to
seven weeks you start to see a lot of
eye scanning and very young infants they
sort of go from looking at the periphery
of the face to scanning the eyes and
they seem to be seeing the face as a
face at that point but these adults with
autism these were very high functioning
adults with autism coming into the into
the laboratory and we put them in front
of our infant I tracker and we were
monitoring their eye movements and they
sort of fundamentally failed to look at
the eyes and as I mentioned they were
high functioning so these were people
that could carry on a conversation the
time I had no clinical background and so
I really couldn't have told you that
they were any different from you know
maybe a slightly awkward person on the
street but they when presented with
these faces failed to look at the eyes
and you can see what they did here's the
little red diamonds it's a bit far away
for you but little red diamonds indicate
individual time points of a fixation
plot and so you see that this person
stared at she actually had an unusual
sha on here over her shoulder when the
person stared at that the whole time
this guy had an unusual feature to his
eyebrow and so this person with autism
stay
at the whole time she had a slightly
suppose unusual lip feature again
focused on that the whole time this is
in contrast to are typically developing
participants which you know 201 tended
to look at the eyes the vast majority of
the time and occasionally did the sort
of triangular scan path every so often
during looking at the eyes to get
information from the rest of the core
facial features looking at the mouth a
little bit looking at the cheeks etc and
so here we had a difference that was
just obvious didn't need statistics to
you know bear it out it fit with
clinical impression but now we had a
quantitative phenotype but we didn't
know why these individuals failed to
look at the ice and this is something
that we've pursued quite vigorously
through our imaging research and i hope
i can tell you about part of that story
today then there was another finding
that intrigued me and this is finding
from Simon baron-cohen slab so Simon
presented kids with autism
developmentally delayed kids and
typically developing children the
developmentally delayed kids didn't have
autism but their IQs were matched to the
kids with autism who had some
intellectual impairment and then
typically developing children and he
showed them Charlie here this is Charlie
and he would say you know which candy is
totally looking at and all the kids
could say in this case the polos he
would say well which candy does Charlie
want right so now link the eye gaze with
a Mentalist ecstatic or a desire the
typically developing kids would say well
the polos because in this context you
know how else can you answer that
question you don't know what Charlie's
favorite candy is but the one he's
looking at is probably an indication of
the one he wants of the one he likes the
developmentally delayed kids with
intellectual impairment but not autism
could answer that question so they were
fine but the kids with autism even the
higher functioning kids with autism
failed to answer that question right so
they couldn't link together the mental
istic significance of this direction of
gaze with you know what it means right
so which candy does Charlie want they
could say which candy with
he was looking at they couldn't make
that leap so what I want to do the rest
of the time is tell you about research
that we've done to follow up on these
behavioral findings and similar
behavioral findings I'm going to tell
you first about our research efforts
designed to just map out the social
brain so looking at typically developing
adults college students like yourself
and putting them in the magnet the
functional MRI machine and monitoring
changes in blood oxygenation level and
trying to figure out how do typically
developing people process social
information and can we chart out the
social brain then I'll talk about how
that's disrupted in adults with autism
okay and then I'll move from there into
what I think is the most exciting stuff
and that is looking at the developing
social brain right so autism is a
disorder of development in order to
understand it as a neurodevelopmental
disorder we have to study children
longitudinally and if preferably very
very young children longitudinally so we
can really get at what is the primary
path of physiology as opposed to what
are the effects of having autism and
living in the world right so I'll try to
make that distinction with some work I
already mentioned that most of what I'll
be talking about today is functional
magnetic resonance imaging is a
technique this is a technique that
allows us to use an endogenous contrast
its present in the brain the fact that
when neurons fire they use more oxygen
and also more blood flows to the region
of neural activity allows us to design
pulse sequences using a large magnet
that very safely and very non-invasively
allow us to monitor a correlative neural
activity okay and so I can talk more
about the limitations of that and what
that means after showing you some of the
science if you're interested alright
so when you think about understanding
other people and this thing that I've
called social perception one of the most
basic aspects to it it's figuring out
when something in the environment it's a
biological agent versus an inanimate
agent or you know a non living thing
that those two things demand very
different processes in order to
understand their behavior all right so
one of the first things we did was try
to define a brain region that codes
differently or responds differently to
biological and non-biological motion in
the way we did this we put people in the
magnet and we showed them this display
so they're wearing virtual reality
goggles and we had this animated display
maybe so often a person would walk as
you just saw or are what we call a robot
would move or what we're calling the
disjointed mechanical figure so the same
parts and movements as the robot but not
conveying the gestalt of walking and
then we had something that's complex and
nameable but it's not biological this
movement of a grandfather clock we tried
to control for as many different
movement parameters as possible so that
at the level of sort of hitting the
retina for example this stimulus and
this stimulus are incredibly similar but
they convey different meanings to you
one is something walking and the other
is a non-biological motion the sort of
random movement okay and what we found
was that this brain region this is an
inflated brain here showing you the
temporal lobe coming down frontal lobes
visual cortex this is the posterior
superior temporal sulcus what you're
seeing is that this brain region is
responding much more strongly to our two
biological compared to non biological
stimulate and so this was very exciting
for us in the sense that now we had a
brain region that was doing the work of
differentiating biological from
non-biological in the environment right
now it's neuroscientist we get really
excited when we see a dissociation and
the idea here is that it's not so
impressive to us if every part of the
brain does something right it's more
impressive if we can localize function
and say this part of the brain does this
this other part of the brain does
something entirely different right so
this part of the brain called v5 which
is just a few that's about a centimeter
back behind the superior temporal sulcus
maybe two centimeters and most people is
responding much more strongly to all
four types of stimuli so it doesn't care
whether it's biological or
non-biological and this is a very
well-known motion processing region that
all primates share that's involved in in
processing motion in general so this is
the part of the brain that allows you to
see movement to begin with all right but
it doesn't care whether it's biological
or non-biological that's done by this
region which is slightly forward to this
one so imagine the processing stream s
goes into the retina back into visual
cortex it's passed to be five it's
recognized as motion and then it's seen
as biological or non biological right so
now we had a nice dissociation because
we had no reason to believe that people
with autism would be disrupted in terms
of their processing of motion in general
but we had a lots of reasons to believe
they would be disrupted in processing
biological motion and that's a story
I'll come back to you in just a few
minutes so we had a brain region that we
deemed involved in social perception
because it's making this differentiation
between biological and non-biological
motion but what we didn't know was
whether it was sort of a a dumb region
that just did that and nothing else or
if it would be sensitive to the context
conveyed by the motion or its intention
right and so I'm using intention and
context relatively interchangeably here
so we wanted to know if it's if it's
sensitive to the intention conveyed the
goal is another word for that then it
would respond differently differently if
we were to manipulate that aspect of the
stimulus presentation so what we did was
put people in the magna and we showed
them a different type of biological
motion this time I movements right and
so think about how important I movements
are to figuring out what other people
are thinking about you know if you're
looking at me it's reasonable to guess
that you're paying attention to me for
example one of the most basic aspects of
this or if you're looking at something
else you're paying attention to that so
what we did was put people in the magnum
they're looking at a virtual reality
figure
this female character and every so often
a checkerboard would appear in her
visual field and sometimes she would
look directly at that checkerboard and
what we were reasoning is that if you're
watching somebody and you know it's just
sort of a plain background and something
appears that's interesting in their
visual field a valid prediction or
reasonable prediction is that they will
look at that object that just appeared
ok so our congruent condition did
exactly that are in congruent condition
required a little bit more of the brain
to figure out because now this
checkerboard appears and it starts
flashing and she looks away right so
what we were doing is borrowing from you
know the handbook of infant psychology
here many many studies of infants have
been done we're looking time is used as
a measure of interest right so in this
case we weren't interested in what the
subjects were doing with their eye
movements but what we were interested in
its what their neurons were doing in
terms of responding longer and stronger
if something didn't meet their
expectation right when I talk about
expectation here I want to be clear that
I'm not talking about the type of
expectation that we commonly think about
in terms of a folk psychological sense
you know the expectation that you're
going to go eat dinner after this and if
it's violated then you know requires
additional processing but it's a very
cognitive type of expectation I'm
talking about a very basic implicit
expectation about what somebody ought to
do in a given context and the reason I
think of this is a very implicit type of
expectation is that the subject see
hundreds of trials of us so and it's
equally likely to for it to be congruent
or in congruent so there's no right
answer here what we're doing is actually
taking advantage of the types of
statistical regularities that these
neurons have seen from birth about what
people tend to do in certain situations
these neurons have essentially learned
to respond differentially to these
incongruent versus congruent situations
in the service of figuring out other
people's intentions that's our argument
so as you might guess well two things
one is that we were able to localize
exactly where in the human brain people
process eye movements so if you wanted
to know that and talk about it at a
cocktail party it's the right posterior
superior temporal sulcus about 35 to 40
millimeters from the anterior commissure
which is right about here right so what
I'm doing is slicing up the brain using
imaging rather than a knife from zero
back to 60 millimeters from the front of
the brain to the back and what I'm
showing you is yellow is the right
hemisphere and each one of these is a
hemodynamic response meaning that the
brain is is active in this location so
what you're seeing is that in the right
hemisphere STS relative to the blue line
which is the left hemisphere you've got
recognition of eye movements in the
brain right so we're excited about this
because on the one hand we were seeing
for the first time we're in the human
brain I gazed processing occurs but then
we found that it actually mattered
whether it was congruent or in congruent
so this opened up a whole new thought
process for us we had a brain region
that's sensitive to biological versus
non biological motion and now we've
localized where in the brain typically
developing people process eye movements
and now we've seen that it matters
whether the movement is goal directed or
not so this brain region in terms of its
role in social perception is involved in
actually representing other people's
intentions right so we wanted to think
about that a little more deeply so we
didn't believe it at first actually and
there were some reasons why we thought
we might have some attentional confounds
etc and we thought well you know it's
not a very strong manipulation of
intention right I mean really do you
have a expectation that somebody's going
to look at something here you know just
because it's only the other thing
they've got to do in the world that's
not very strong so instead we gave
people an intention or next
tation right so we put people in the
magnet and we had them watch Kaitlyn
here Kaitlyn's my lab manager so Caitlin
looked at the red cup and she expressed
positive regard if I had the sound
turned on you would hear Kaitlyn go oh
and then she reaches for the red cup so
here in this situation given the red cup
in the green cup kalyn's expressed
liking the red cup and then her next
action is to pick up the red cup right
now here's another so she likes the red
one but she picks up the green one so
this is very very similar to the last
study I showed you but now we've sort of
knocked our subjects over the head with
no Caitlin likes the red one so your
brain starts to make this implicit
expectation that she's going to pick up
the red one and then we violate it we
wanted to make it a little bit more
complicated and also control for visual
attention whoops so we presented Caitlin
disliking the green one she says yuck
and then she picks up the red one well
in this case it's actually the congruent
thing to do to reach into the other side
of the table and that was important to
control for spatial attention then she
likes the green one dislikes the green
one sorry i got the conditions mixed up
as I was describing them but she picks
it up alright so how often do you see
somebody pick up the thing that they
expressed that they dislike when they
could have just as easily pick up the
other one right so what we predicted was
that in the incongruent cases you would
see additional activity in the superior
temporal sulcus in the right hemisphere
in the posterior section of it and
that's exactly what we saw so we had a
replication of our prior finding that
this posterior STS region is involved in
processing biological motion and it's
sensitive to intentions right
so that's the last part i'm going to
show you that just involves typically
developing people because at this point
in the research program we felt like we
had a good enough understanding of this
particular component of the social brain
to start trying to understand something
about autism alright so what we did
given that study I showed you of Simon
baron cohen's what would you predict
would happen if I put some subjects with
autism into the magnet and scan them
looking at Caitlyn or that other study
that I showed you with the Avatar to
look towards the checker border or away
from it what would you predict they
wouldn't show a difference specifically
we're right in the STS location right so
they wouldn't differentiate the expected
and the unexpected because presumably
they're not forming those expectations
and that brain region isn't supporting
that formation of the expectation so
what we found so we put them in the
magnet we showed them our in congruent
versus congruent avatars and what we
found was that typically developing
people in the right superior temporal
sulcus differentiating congruent and
congruent just as we thought they would
and replicating the old studies but in
the individuals with autism they failed
to represent that intention so they're
responding equivalently to the
incongruent and to the congruent in a
sense it's as though their brain region
is giving a closer representation of
reality because those to stimulate down
to the pixel are actually identical in
terms of how much movement that can bay
so from the point of view of the retina
those are exactly the same stimulus and
we counterbalanced or side of
presentation of the checkerboard etc to
make sure of that so many brain regions
and the typically developing people
respond perfectly equivalently it's
whether or not you form that expectation
that drives that spear triple sulcus
activity and the individuals with autism
we're failing to do that so having just
told you that as a group they fail to
form that expectation they they fail to
to show that differential activity of
their spiritual sulcus lacks that
differentiation now I'm going to tell
you that there was a lot of individual
variability in that okay so the one
thing if you haven't been told already
that's absolutely true in autism is that
it's incredibly heterogeneous right so
even though we'll call two people will
say you know they both have autism the
presentation of the autism can be very
very different and one of the dimensions
upon which it can vary is in the
severity of the social dysfunction so
what we did was go in and look at the
difference between in congruent and
congruent in the spear temple sulcus and
we said okay in this region this is a
measure of of intactness of this brain
region does it co vary with social
dysfunction and we used as our measure
of social dysfunction the ADI or the
autism diagnostic interview revised and
there's a sub component of it called the
social interaction square and this is
that one of the gold standard techniques
that we use to diagnose autism
particularly for research purposes so
that we know that the people were
studying have autism so all of these
people met criteria for autism but they
still varied in terms of the severity of
autism and as it turned out there was a
very very strong correlation between the
severity of their autism and the measure
of intactness of their act superior
temporal sulcus region so if they have a
superior temporal sulcus region that was
more normal compared to the rest of the
group then they had fewer difficulties
in social interaction what was exciting
to us about this is that here we had a
measure a biological measure that Co
varied with the severity of autism so in
a way we start to one we started to
wonder could we use this measure to
predict outcome for example in children
with autism we don't know yet how severe
it's going to be but now do we have a
measure that would allow us to start to
be able to say well this child is going
to have more dysfunction than this trial
based on the brain we had a biomarker
for the severity of autism so again one
of the things that you'll learn about
Imaging Research and autism is that it's
very very important to replicate there
are many
many many results about the brain and
autism that have failed to be replicated
and so in their vast region reasons for
that and so it's important to try to
replicate in this case we replicated
within our lab I'd rather see this
replicated across two labs so I'm hoping
that somebody will follow up this
finding although several people have
found dysfunction the superior temporal
sulcus at this point but we followed it
up in our lab using this katelyn task
with the green and the red cups etc and
what we found was that we could very
nicely replicate our finding and
typically developing participants I
apologize for the yellow on the white
screen this says yellow equals study to
read equals study 1 so what you see is
that the regions of activation are
perfectly overlapping between two
different studies done on two different
magnets right and then we found that
individuals with autism again fail to
differentiate in their superior temporal
sulcus the incongruent versus the
congruent activity so again another
indication that something is
dysfunctional in this specific brain
region and here's your typically
developing results but notice how big
these standard error bars are okay so
there's lots of variability in the
script still so this time around we had
more information about who these
subjects were in particular we had
collected genetic material so we knew
their genome and in particular we had
genotype them for uh for a particular
allele that's a particular gene called
the serotonin transporter gene this gene
is involved in regulating the amount of
serotonin in the brain and one of the
old biological findings now and
controversial but for the most part
replicated is that individuals with
autism have differences in terms of
their amount of serotonin that they have
circulating in their blood and
differences in serotonin synthesis in
the brain and so we thought well this is
a reasonable gene to go after in
addition the serotonin transporter gene
has been linked to other components of
the social brain in particular the
amygdala so we thought okay we have this
gene we've mapped it in everybody let's
see what happens in terms of our sample
of individuals with autism
and what we found was that individuals
that had the long long configuration so
different configurations if you have a
short allele on your serotonin
transporter gene then you have more
amygdala activity in general and you
have higher levels of serotonin
circulating in your brain and in your
blood so these individuals the low loves
with autism now everybody here has
autism in this bottom graph but these
are the individuals with the long long
it seems to be a protective factor for
exhibiting dysfunction in the right
posterior superior temporal sulcus so
their social brain is more normal by
virtue of having this gene and then
conversely they have a short allele
their social brain is more disrupted
right so they're actually driving this
effect so here we have a gene linked to
a particular I think important aspect of
the social phenotype in autism then
linked to a brain region so we can start
to understand how if you have autism
that autism is against a background of
different genes from person to person
and we can begin to understand some of
the variability in the autism phenotype
by understanding other aspects not
necessarily the genes that cause autism
but the genes that are related to social
functioning in general and how those
overlay on the genes that cause autism
that gives you ultimately a variable
phenotype right and that's what I think
we've done in this particular study and
it's worth noting that it really doesn't
matter what genotype you have if you're
typically developing your superior
temporal sulcus still differentiates and
congruent from congruent it only begins
to matter if you have the autism
overlaid on top of that genome okay that
particular gene all right good
thank you in both our study and also a
much larger study done by Cathy Lord she
found that she didn't have imaging data
but she looked at kids longitudinally
and the ones that ended up having this
the worst or the more difficult social
phenotype had the short allele the
serotonin transporter gene and then in
our study as well the lower Adi scores
in terms of greater social deficits
we're in the kids that had the short
allele alright but it doesn't go very
with IQ so it doesn't affect
intellectual functioning it seems to be
specifically related to the social
impairments and one thing I didn't say
about our prior imaging data and also
Cathy's data and the serotonin
transporter story is that it's not
related to repetitive behaviors or
language abilities it seems to be
specifically related to the social
abilities right thank you so I'm going
to leave the superior temporal sulcus
for a second and take you to a different
brain region now one that's on the
bottom surface of the brain again in the
temporal lobe and I want to talk about
this notion of why individuals with
autism might fail to look at the eyes
and so this is particularly intriguing I
think to clinicians in terms of you know
how do you interact with children with
autism there's some suggestion that sort
of making individuals with autism look
you in the eye that's what this book is
about will tend to cause some anxiety or
some some painful sensations and the
individuals with autism that this is
just overwhelming and disturbing so we
wanted to know well we started with the
finding that in this face area of the
fusiform gyrus there's hypo activation
and that was a well replicated finding
but the suggestion was given the
findings of differences and eye
movements that I've already shown you
well is it the case that you're just
sort of scanning apples and oranges in
that the individuals with autism simply
aren't looking at the eyes
so it isn't that they're fusiform gyrus
is disrupted it's just that they don't
look at the eyes and they don't develop
expertise for faces and so they're
fusiform never develops that
specialization for faces so if it's if
it's disrupted its disrupted because of
that right so what we did was actually
put the subjects in the magna and we
showed them a face which is a strong
stimulus to illicit activity in the
fusiform and we monitor their eye
movements right so most studies prior to
this sorry not monitor their eye
movements we actually experimentally
manipulated their eye movements most
studies prior to this had either
monitored the eye movements and noted a
correlation between looking at the eyes
and fusiform activity or they had simply
failed to control eye movements at all
right so we had a correlation that
suggested that our hypothesis that by
manipulating the scan paths we might see
more normal function was true but it was
just a correlation at that point so we
experimentally manipulated eye movements
and we had several conditions one was
fixation so you've got a crosshair that
would appear to single crosshair and it
would kind of jump around right around
in the nose the center of the face okay
then we had free viewing and as the name
implies subjects were allowed to look in
any way they wished and this was very
similar to all the studies that have
been done prior to this then we had lo
looking at the eyes so here we have
sometimes the crosshair would land on
the eyes but it would also land on other
features and all features entirely then
we had medium looking at that and then
we add hi so by the time we got to high
we had about 50 s / six percent of the
time spent looking at the eyes which is
we picked this range given what we knew
about typically developing people who
tend to exhibit a range between thirty
two percent and fifty six percent
interestingly as a side note that
actually very strongly with personality
in particular if you're highly neurotic
you spend lots of time looking at other
people's eyes if you're very low in the
personality trait of neuroticism you
look very little at the ice and also
neuroticism Co varies with the serotonin
transporter
so you know one of the things if you're
highly neurotic or anxious person a
doctor might prescribe a selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitor and that's
how that works it alters that genes
expression so back to the study so what
we predicted was that in individuals
with autism in the free viewing
condition they would fail to show
activation in the fusiform gyrus and
that was a known thing already but as we
move to more looking at the eyes we
would actually increase activation in
their fusiform gyrus in a way this is an
experimental demonstration of the the
frequent habit of clinicians to
encourage eye contact and children with
autism is one of the most basic things
that you do in interacting with these
kids in an intervention setting and here
we're trying to see how this might work
in an experimental setting by putting
them in the magnet right so what we
found was that just during free viewing
we replicated very nicely studies we had
done studies Bob Schultz had done other
people as well that the fusiform gyrus
it's right here was much more strongly
activated in the typically developing
people compared to the individuals with
autism now in addition this brain region
is called the amygdala right so you see
by lateral amygdala activation that's
stronger for the typically developing
people then for the individuals with
autism this is another finding that has
been seen a few times during free
viewing in in studies of individuals
with and without autism all right the
amygdala is actually thought to help
direct your attention to salient things
in the environment things that you don't
understand things that you understand
but are very emotionally salient to you
alright so the amygdala has long been of
interest to people studying autism
because it's a brain region that helps
you sort of emotionally tag the topology
of salience of things in the environment
typically leading you to look more
people's faces than to other things
right
now when we manipulated eye movements
though during free viewing you see this
nice differentiation between individuals
with autism here coded in red red
squares and blue circles for the
typically developing individuals so you
see nice differentiation in the overall
level of activation from the fusiform
when you make people that are typically
developing fixate on the center of the
nose you actually drop their level of
activity significantly right and you
make them look just like individuals
with autism and you bring individuals
with autism slightly up by making them
fixate on the nose all right so a
significant jump already from just free
viewing where presumably they're not
looking at the eyes much at all to
central fixation just look at the center
of the nose then as you move it to low
eyes you see that it back to normal
levels for typically developing people
and then after that it really doesn't
matter how much you make typically
developing people look at the eyes
they're fusiform still response but the
individuals with autism you see a nice
increase from low to medium and then it
levels off and there's no difference
between high and medium so in essence
what we're showing here is that
individuals with autism appear to have a
functional fusiform gyrus it's being
masked by the behavior the exhibit right
so they're not looking at the eyes one
of the very best things to drive the
fusiform response is eyes if you remove
the eyes from face and you present the
face the fusiform will still respond
it'll be a weaker response and typically
developing individuals and indeed when
you make individuals with autism look at
the eyes you see normal levels of
fusiform gyrus activity but how about
the amygdala so it appears that
individuals with autism have an intact
fusiform it's being masked by their eye
movements this actually has implications
for theories of where the fusiform comes
from to begin with so there's a huge
debate within the world of psychology
about whether or not the fusiform face
area is involved in processing faces per
se versus other categories of objects
for which you have visual expertise and
one of the key far
cited by individuals that hold this sort
of expertise point of view is that well
individuals with autism don't have
expertise for faces and they lack a
fusiform gyrus and that's consistent
with the theory and what I'm saying is
well actually they have a fusiform gyrus
it's responsive to faces even though
they lack expertise for faces in any
definition of the term and they tend to
do whole parts base versus configurable
processing etc so this data is actually
evidence against an expertise point of
view and in favor of a more modular or
face processing region as a face
processing region point of view but the
amygdala well the amygdala only responds
and typically developing people when you
don't make them look at the eyes and at
first we found that counterintuitive we
thought well we know the eyes you know
contain most of the emotional
information in the face especially a
fearful face like the one we showed here
why is it that when you make them look
more at the eyes you diminish activity
and it doesn't matter at all whether you
make individuals with autism look at the
ice right still zero activity all the
way across the board so we couldn't
recover a Migdal activity but we could
recover fusiform activity so again
showing an association there so the way
we're interpreting in this is that we
think that this brain region is actually
involved in distributing visual
attention I movements to the eyes so to
answer the question well why don't
individuals with autism look at the eyes
well I think it's primarily because of
an amygdala dysfunction okay this is
consistent with what other people have
theorized as well but I think here we
have experimental proof showing that you
can recover activation in one brain
region but not in the amygdala and the
amygdala seems to only be involved in
typically developing people when you
leave them to their own devices when the
amygdala has a job to do which is to
direct eye movements otherwise you're
taking the amygdala out of the loop and
you see a zero activation in it okay
okay so everything I've told you about
excuse me
so far is focused on studying adult
individuals with autism and typically
developing adults right so the problem
with that is that everything we're
seeing could as well be the result of
having autism for many years as opposed
to any type of primary pathophysiology
and that's a big issue in the field of
neuroimaging and one that we're all
wrestling with and the answer is to try
to study younger and younger children so
I'm going to tell you about our efforts
to do that so I mentioned that the MRI
machine uses this endogenous contrast
that it's non-invasive and and perfectly
safe it is nonetheless very loud very
imposing and you know not at all a
pleasant experience so you're getting
into this big tube and it makes lots of
noise and you're kind of slid back into
the tube and you're told to be perfectly
still for the whole time not things that
kids in general or good at and
particularly not the kids with autism so
we have to figure out ways to make this
as attractive as possible and as
manageable as possible for the kids and
so what we do is to take the the
imposing magnet and try to make it much
more friendly one step that we take is
to use a fake scanner so this is called
a mock scanner and we we build a mock
scanner that has a lot of the same parts
as the actual MRI scanner but it doesn't
have the magnet so you can crawl all
over it you know there's no safety
concerns and you crawl inside it etc and
then we put facades in front of the
magnet which are actually painted on
fiberglass so that they can be brought
into the real magnet and I keep
mentioning magnet and indeed it's a huge
magnet that's always on so you can't
walk into the room and have any type of
metal anywhere you know in your pockets
because it will fly out and and if
there's a subject in the middle of the
bore the metal will be drawn very very
rapidly to the center of the bore and
can actually hurt somebody very very
badly so it's important that these are
drawn on non-magnetic material
non-magnetic paints and so we we
introduce the child with autism
typically developing child to Thomas the
Tank Engine here or the rocket ship and
this becomes a game and so the game is
to get inside of Thomas to take
or get inside of the rocketship and show
us how still you can be play the statute
gig and as you play the statue game you
know you progress through this process
and you learn how to be still for
extended periods of time so we have a
device that actually monitors head
movement this is a child in the magnet
this is a radiofrequency head coil which
is used to take images of the brain
she's wearing glasses that allow her to
see behind her head and back here we
have an LCD monitor that's playing her
favorite movie then we have this little
device here that's a little magnet
that's being monitored in space this is
a readout of how much she's moving this
is in millimeter increments so you can
see some movements here from zero to 10
millimeters if she gets beyond 10
millimeters then the computer program
actually shuts off her favorite movie
and so therefore she doesn't get the
thing that she's enjoying watching
writing kids get this game very very
quickly at first it's fun to make it
start and stop and then they want to be
still so they can watch their favorite
movie and so what were able to do by
doing this is actually scan kids all the
way down to the age of four years while
they're awake in the magnet you know
behaving and being still all right so
that for us was a big conceptual a big
practical leap forward and it allowed us
to ask a lot more interesting science
questions about the development of the
social brain and individuals with autism
so one of the first things we did was go
after this idea of whether or not
individuals with autism differentiate
biological from non-biological motion so
we showed the stimulate I was showing
you earlier at this time we showed it
two very young children with autism and
indeed what we found was that in these
kids remember my plot before the
superior temporal sulcus this is the
exact same idea going from the front of
the brain to the back typically
developing kids nicely differentiate
biological from non-biological motion
again about 40 to 50 millimeters back
into the brain okay right hemisphere
sorry biological motion and yellow non
biological motion in blue but the
children with autism failed to make that
differentiation all along their superior
temporal sulcus
so here's we have a biological basis for
the failure to perceive biological
motion properly in these children with
autism this is showing you a summary
activation and again showing you that
what I'm trying to put forward is not a
view that the entire brain is different
or all aspects of information processing
different are different in autism what
I'm trying to convey is that social
information processing and social
information processing regions are
affected in autism specifically right
what this is showing is that the
posterior STS is differentiating typical
development from autism it's
dysfunctional in autism but again that's
our area that we talked about before v5
it's behaving perfectly normal on autism
so the prediction would be that if
individuals with autism would perceive
motion just fine but when called upon to
make the differentiation between
biological and non-biological motion
those individuals have problems doing
that and indeed that's exactly what you
see behaviorally so here we have again
evidence for dysfunction in a specific
brain region we followed this up as as
I've tried to hit you over the head with
it's always very very important to
replicate every finding in the field of
autism we follow this up with point
light walkers and this was stimulate
that were borrowed from ami Klin and
warren jones and colleagues that convey
these sort of complex very rich social
actions this is the now famous
patty-cake video conveyed through point
light displays okay and what army and
colleagues found was that when you
compared non-biological to biological
motion very very young infants with
autism failed to orient preferentially
to the biological versus the
non-biological motion and then others
have found that children with autism
failed to differentiate biological and
non-biological motion older kids so we
showed biological motion versus a
scrambled control
okay and so what we found in this case
we had three groups of subjects all
right Jamie we goin til five right okay
excellent so what we found was that in
three groups of subjects is something
that I think is very very interesting
neurotypical individuals yellow and
orange here showing you where biological
is greater than non biological motion
okay so you see that in regions in the
left hemisphere that are typically
thought to be involved in language
production and naming things and
language understanding and semantic
understanding here so Broca's area
Bernanke's area motion processing
regions v5 is right there and the
superior temporal sulcus all strongly
more active to biological the non
biological motion right then you can see
here in the right superior temporal
sulcus much stronger activity two
biological versus non biological motion
also in the bilateral fusiform Gyrene
okay now then we had these are
neurotypical kids these are just
typically developing five to 11 year
olds then we had unaffected siblings of
children with autism so these are kids
that do not have autism but they're
related their sibling of a child that
does have autism and those were our
third group the kids with autism right
so what we were thinking when we first
started the study is that these would be
an excellent control group for kids with
autism because they're growing up in
families where you know they're being
affected by autism but they don't have
the the phenotype they don't have the
disorder okay so what we found out was
that the unaffected siblings actually
showed decreased activity in superior
temple sulcus in this / idle cortical
region that likely corresponds to
Bernanke's area and also in this frontal
region that corresponds to Broca's area
right so they were showing evidence of a
brain phenotype that was actually much
more consistent with the brain phenotype
that you see in autism than in the
typically developing kids and that was
striking to us because what it suggested
was that we had here a picture of a
vulnerability for developing autism a
brain vulnerability or a brain phenotype
or what
we'll talk about in terms of indo
phenotypes something that doesn't give
rise to the full full-blown disorder but
it's still a trace of the vulnerability
for developing that disorder on the
basis of your biological constitution ok
so again they don't have autism so
nothing you're seeing here is the result
of autism there's no differences in
expertise etc their brain is showing a
differentiation based on a different
vulnerability to autism right and so
follow this up we also looked at the
amygdala so you see that individuals
with autism completely lack of Migdal
activation to these stimulate unaffected
siblings are showing only unilateral
amygdala activation typically developing
people have it in both hemispheres and
also this was very interesting to us
this activation here as it corresponds
to reward circuitry in the brain so here
you had regions that are known to be
involved in very simple rewards like
delivery of cocaine actually in rats and
when you get paid a little bit of money
or when you know a hand at poker these
are the regions that come online when
you see a beautiful person these are the
regions that come online and what
they're doing is coming online in these
typically developing people for
biological greater than non biological
motion but they're not coming online in
the unaffected siblings or in the
individuals with autism so it's as
though they're not finding Lee stimulate
rewarding in any way shape form or
fashion now we don't have behavioral
data we didn't ask the subjects did you
find those rewarding but using this
imaging technique we were able to see
brain regions that are consistent with
those interpretations differentiating
these groups and failing to
differentiate these two groups and then
finally you know it's it's equally
important to see a brain region that
works so this is v5 we had a little bit
more motion and our biological compared
to our non biological stimulate and
indeed v5 revealed this so it's
equivalently active in all three groups
right so what I want to convey is that
autism is not a disorder of all aspects
of information processing it appears to
be a disorder that that most strongly
affects social information
and I think that's what we're we're
seeing here so one of the things that
we're getting into now given this data
concerning a vulnerability for
developing autism but the lack of the
actual full-blown phenotype we're deeply
interested now in taking this even
younger so what we want to do now is
look at infant siblings of people with
autism so these are our kids that you
know they're newborns they come into the
lab and they're seeing longitudinally
over time and they're seen because
they're an increased risk given the
heritability of autism so it runs and
families we know that these individuals
if they have a first degree relative
with autism or more likely to develop
autism but they haven't yet and we
compare those two kids that are at
normal risk for developing autism and we
watch them over development so what we
want to do next is now not only watch
them behaviorally but start to try to
understand how their brain is
functioning throughout this period of
development to see who could we predict
which individuals would develop autism
versus those that don't we also want to
start to try to intervene because one of
the strongest tests of our hypothesis
about this being a disorder of social
brain function is to have a social
information processing intervention that
would happen very very early in life
before the identification of the autism
and then see if we can set a number of
kids on a different trajectory so we
watched how their braids actually alters
as a result of having that sort of
enhancement in social information
processing delivered to them very very
early on and we're talking about you
know playing with the children and
specific ways in ways designed to
actually improve social brain
functioning and then monitoring the
outcome as a measure of brain function
okay
so what's important in order to be able
to do this is to have techniques that
allow us to look at brain function in
very very young infants if Jamie hasn't
spoken already he'll talk extensively
about evoked response potentials which
are one really wonderful way of looking
at brain function even in very very
young infants another way is to actually
use MRI and functional MRI which I've
been talking about the entire time it
has some limitations though for scanning
infants they have to be asleep while
you're scanning them because again it's
a noisy somewhat scary environment and
another way to actually image brain
function is using infrared light so if
any of you have ever been to the doctor
and had your pulse taken with a pulse
oximeter the notion is that they shine
infrared light through your finger and
that infrared light bends differently
and responds differently depending on
how much oxygen is in the blood so it's
infrared light will pass right through
skin and to some degree bone but it's
stopped by different properties of the
blood and therefore reflects differently
so you can measure oxygen so the
principle here is that infants actually
have quite thin skulls so optical
imaging works quite well with them so
talk for a minute about near-infrared
spectroscopy so one of the things that
we're doing is using this type of
technique to begin to scan very very
young infants and with some success this
is Liam who's a child of one of the
research scientists in the lab and Liam
has a hat on that has transmission and
reception up toads these are little
opt-outs and they're connected fiber
optic cables that go back into a laser
the laser generates near-infrared light
which is perfectly safe to tissue you
get a you're getting a lot of mirin for
a light now actually we walk outside in
the sunlight you get lots of infrared
light actually passing through your
skull and so liam is having on the balut
and the red here light is being emitted
and it's traveling through the skull in
a diffuse pattern but it tends to sort
of take a banana route most strongly
it's reflected off of the cortical
surface and back to this little blue one
here which is a receiver and we measure
the properties of that light as its
transmitted and received and we can make
inferences about underlying neural
activity particularly via oxygen levels
so it's the same exact measure as fMRI
but done with light instead of a loud
magnet right so why don't we do this
instead of fMRI all the time well you're
limited very very clearly in terms of
how deep you can go so for example you
can't study the amygdala with this
technique unfortunately but you can
certainly study the superior temporal
sulcus of the fusiform gyrus both of
which are surface features on the cortex
rather than deep brain structures so
we've been doing this this is a showing
you the number of op toads that we have
in this case in the study we were
wrapping them around the back of the
head and these op toads here we're
hitting the superior temporal sulcus and
lo and behold when we looked at our fMRI
data from that study involving Kaitlin
reaching for the red and green cups
here's the fMRI activation and from this
recording opt out what we found was a
stronger response to the in congruent
versus the congruent it's a solid versus
dashed line so excited about this in
terms of being able to take into
studying infants something very some a
high level in terms of social perception
and social cognition so we think that
infants based on behavioral work can
make these sort of incongruity or scan
gruen intention distinctions and now we
can study how their brain is doing that
in this particular region and then we
can begin to study the kids that are at
high risk for developing autism versus
the kids that are low risk for
developing autism so if you were in this
class next year I would hope to be
showing you data that might
differentiate those two groups of
individuals and therefore give us some
measure of prediction and also hopefully
some measure of response to treatment in
the individuals that are at low and high
risk for developing autism the last
thing I want to show you is something
that particularly those of you that are
going to be working with the low
functioning kids with autism at Ben
Haven are going to come up against but
all individuals with autism tend to have
a tendency
towards emotion dysregulation it's
something that's very challenging for
children with autism to learn because
one of the primary means by which you
learn emotion regulation is through
social interactions with others so if
your dysfunctional in terms of your
social interactions then you're far
behind in your ability to actually
regulate emotion just from the starting
point so we've been developing ways to
study emotion regulation right so again
it's not a primary characteristic of
autism many people have emotion
dysregulation but it tends to be more
true of individuals with autism than
individuals without autism and it's
something that's very troubling to
parents so if you're the parent of a
child with autism you go into a grocery
store a lot of times it feels like it's
only a matter of time before there's a
meltdown and it usually ends and you
leaving the grocery store prior to being
able to get what you came for so with
people looking at you in a funny way so
we developed this task to study emotion
regulation and young children in the
magnet so the kids are playing a game
all right and they see a series of green
and red squares and inside of those
green and red squares or just common
objects and we also show faces not
central to the point I'm going to make
but the faces are there so when they see
a red one their job is to not press the
button and when they see a green one
their job is to press a button so this
is called a go/no-go task it's a very
typical kind of tasks for people who are
studying cognitive inhibition right but
what makes it an emotion regulation task
is that before they play the game
they're told all right if you win you're
going to get a picture of your brain and
you're going to be able to put your name
on the wall of fame and I want you to go
over to the table where you see all
those really cool toys pick one out
because you're going to be able to take
it home but only if you win if you lose
you're out of luck all right so there's
lots of demand already they pick out a
toy they play with it for a few minutes
they show it to their parents and then
we take it away and we put it on the
table and we say well if you win
you get to leave with this and then we
put them in the magnet and they're
playing this game but unbeknownst to
them there are three blocks to this game
at the beginning of the game everybody
wins right so it's pretty easy you're
winning and you're being told you know
by this little guy here that you're
winning points right he comes up every
so often there's a little thermometer
that shows you in real time how many
points you got how close you are to your
goal all right we even put a little
picture of the toy they want on top of
that thermometer but then in the middle
block everybody loses so this is like a
game at the you know durham fair no
matter how good you are you're going to
lose most of the time so every kid at
this point is losing and now they've got
to emotionally regulate because they're
going to lose from their perspective
something that's very very important to
them right so we bring kids almost of
the point of sort of meltdown by
modifying the difficulty of this task
and because we can modify in real time
how fast the task is going how hard it
is we can make everybody behave or
perform at the same level which is
really important in interpreting brain
activity right so everybody's losing to
the same degree they almost lose all
their points and then in the third block
everybody wins because the first rule of
child psychology is that everyone leaves
the lab a winner so but they don't know
this and then they have to inhibit the
opposite of a negative emotion which is
I'm winning I'm getting what I want and
oftentimes in life that's also something
that you have to learn to emotionally
regulate sort of being a sore winner
when you're getting what you want and
and not sort of taking your mind off of
the task so if you play sports if you if
you're up three goals in a soccer game
and you stop playing defense you've got
to kind of emotionally regulate even
though you're winning right so we can
study regulation by subtracting this
block when now a strong negative mood
has been induced by the losing block
from this block which is winning and
presumably doesn't require any emotion
ulation or not as much and we can then
identify brain regions that are involved
and just to show you that the task
actually worked when the kids got out of
the magnet we asked them you know well
what are we thinking and so this child
aged ten I thought I was going to lose
all my points I was very worried so
showing that the the block to actually
did work it was sad when I was losing
but I knew I would really win and so
that's actually an example of an emotion
regulation strategy where you reframe
something to be not as bad when I was
losing I pretended that all the bad
faces were really happy that's actually
a very sophisticated emotion regulation
strategy so you know if you're giving a
talk and it's going poorly pretend
everybody's clapping for you so
sophisticated little five to eleven year
olds and what we found was that when we
looked inside of brain regions that are
involved in motion or emotion regulation
one of them is the anterior cingulate so
this is the very center of the brain
this is the corpus callosum and above
that as a strip of cortex called the
anterior cingulate cortex right and in
regions that are at the top of that
cortex here called the dorsal anterior
cingulate those are known to be involved
in of higher level strategies for
emotion regulation things like reframing
or pretending it isn't that bad or
thinking about something else things
that demand some cognitive ability to be
able to do while you're under a lot of
stress but down here in ventral anterior
cingulate cortex these are things this
is a brain region that's known to be
involved in the experience of negative
emotion and in very kind of primitive
strategies for emotion regulation and
what we found was that the dorsal
anterior cingulate its response during
this block nicely followed age so as
children grew older their dorsal
anterior cingulate became more online
block 3 versus block 1 their ventral
anterior cingulate went down an activity
so these kids are older and have less
activation in this ventral region so
it's showing you dynamically in the
brain over
this sort of half decade of development
how the brain normally begins to use one
brain region versus another for emotion
regulation and all of us know this you
know and interacting with kids that
older kids are better in general at
regulating emotion but what this gives
us is a sense of what the normative
profile is for the development of
emotion regulation and then I insight
into you as we're looking at this in
autism how that deviates in kids with
autism and therefore potentially a place
where we could go in and intervene a
target of intervention so however we all
know that there are some people who
never really get emotion regulation
hopefully none of them are your
roommates but there are some people for
whom emotion regulation is just really
difficult they tend to be people who are
very high in neuroticism and they tend
to be people who experience a lot of
negative effect and a lot of fear and in
children we call that a negative or a
fearful temperament so we measured
temperament so now this is irrespective
of age when you look at fear scores so
higher scores me and children who are
more fearful these are kids that are
extremely shy that tend to be afraid of
everything new etc etc these kids have
lower dorsal anterior cingulate activity
and higher ventral anterior cingulate
activity so what this was giving us as a
measure is a it's a biological brain
measure of activity that relates to
aspects of temperament and temperament
becomes personality as children develop
and so what we're seeing here is the
beginnings of differences in what we
think will be long-term outcomes in
terms of how these children emotionally
regulate so now as we move this into the
world of autism we could begin to to
perhaps diagnose those kids that are
particularly going to have particular
trouble and developing emotion
regulation strategies and those could
become the kids that receive specific
interventions aimed at increasing
emotion regulation strategies which we
don't think will affect their autism per
se but will certainly make it easier for
other individuals to work on the
characteristics of autism versus having
the
with his emotion regulation deficits you
know throughout their life and so let's
see I think that's all I want to say and
since we're videotaping this I'll put up
the financial disclosures we're very
fortunate to have lots of funding from
outside agencies and to do things like
support undergraduate projects if I've
managed to interest you today and that's
it